Those are the viewers who don't know.
Headstart was a nationwide attempt to,
to add additional education to the lives of disadvantaged kids,
especially,
you know,
at the,
at the preschool level.
And basically what happened,
what was that they actually did show improvements in academic achievement
initially.
So in grade one and grade two they were performing above their peers.
But then the difference in improvement,
the difference in performance started to decrease and then by both the grade
grade five,
grade six that differences and disappeared completely.
So there was no evidence whatsoever of that,
of that either have a stable one time,
longterm gain in cognitive ability or what people were really hoping was that if
you intervene early enough,
you get something that would sort of,
Paul would turn into a positive feedback loop and the gains would actually
advance across time.
And what ended up happening with the headstart research basically was the
conclusion that it produced no cognitive improvements whatsoever.
Although more kids who went through headstart,
um,
graduated from high school,
fewer of them were delinquent,
more of them,
fewer of them became pregnant teenage in the teenage years.
And more of them went to colleges.
But that seemed to be because they were better socialized,
not because they were in any way.
It had been made smarter.
So that was a really tremendous disappointment because it was a bipartisan
attempt to come to grips with the fundamental issues that sort of be deviled
structural poverty in the United States.
No one was happy about that outcome.
I can tell you.